608 let's now go to politics and we have
exclusive insight this morning at the
heated races for governor and senate we
have a new eight news now the hill
emerson college poll it focuses on the
republican field and where things stand
before next month's primary this morning
your first look at the numbers
not what your country can do the ads are
everywhere
a crowded field of republicans jockeying
for position before the june primary a
bunch of keyboard cowboys in the
governor's race clark county sheriff joe
lombardo leads in fundraising our poll
shows he also leads with voters we asked
republicans who they would choose in the
primary lombardo came in at 32 and a
half percent attorney joey gilbert
endorsed by the nevada gop came in
second about 18 points behind former
senator dean heller and north las vegas
mayor john lee came third and fourth
things shift when we asked undecided
republicans where they're leaning
lombardo has a six point lead over lee
followed closely by heller gilbert comes
in fourth donald trump who supposedly
has all this currency with the party
base has endorsed lombardo but the party
base is not listening to donald trump
when it comes to to these results it
looks like
they're they're sticking with their man
joey gilbert adam laxalt i'm sam brown
it's a two-candidate race for the senate
gop primary former attorney general adam
laxalt being challenged by newcomer and
wounded army veteran sam brown among
republican voters laxalt leads with
roughly half of those polled brown comes
in at 27 percent former miss nevada
shirelle mendenhall has four percent
undecided republicans are also leaning
towards lax salt brown is around 26
percent while mendenhall jumps up to 13
brown had virtually no name id at all
he's a newcomer to the state
um it's only i think his second race in
in politics in general
adam laxalt's been running for a long
time he's a former statewide office
holder on paper there should be no
contest no doubt former president donald
trump still looms large within the gop
our poll shows 54 percent of republicans
are more likely to choose someone
endorsed by mr trump he's already put
his support behind lombardo for governor
and lacked salt for senate after june
14th
at that point i think you're going to
see those candidates forget who donald
trump is
and say no thank you mr president we
don't need a rally here in nevada we're
good
steve sibelius of course from the las
vegas review journal we talked to him a
lot about politics worth pointing out we
conducted our poll of a thousand likely
republican voters between april 28 and
may 2nd the margin of error plus or
minus 3 percent how